buenas tardes a todos ya todas
hoy les quisiera hablar sobre un tema
del que poco se habla realmente aquí en
amenaza el machismo todos todos sabemos
que amenaza la vida de las mujeres es
cosa de los periódicos cada día de ver
las noticias para darnos cuenta la
gravedad del problema pero sabemos
realmente como amenaza el machismo la
vida de los hombres
es un riesgo hoy día nacer hombre el 80
por ciento de los homicidios que se
cometen en el mundo así como quienes
perpetran los homicidios son hombres
es una estadística abrumadora
realmente nacer hombre es un factor de
riesgo en centroamérica es una situación
particularmente grave nueve de cada diez
personas que van a morir asesinada su
nombre
uno de cada cincuenta hombres mayor de
veinte años va a morir antes de cumplir
los 31 años
es decir una gran mortandad de hombres
jóvenes está ocurriendo en centroamérica
y la razón principal son los
condicionamientos culturales que empujan
a los hombres hacia morir demostrando su
hombría en honduras 91% de las víctimas
de homicidio fueron hombre el año pasado
en argentina igual el 86 por ciento de
las muertes por agresión corresponden a
hombres y el 80 por ciento de los
suicidios y en mexico de 205 mil
privados de libertad el 95 por ciento su
nombre o sea imagínense los riesgos de
vivir la masculinidad de esta manera
los hombres son víctimas del machismo
pero muchos no lo saben y si lo saben
callan por temor al rechazo no hablan de
este tema no se discute este tema los
hombres sufren el machismo cuando tienen
que demostrarlo midiendo fuerza con
otros hombres para ver quién tiene más
poder y así corren el riesgo de ser
heridos mutilados matados privados de
libertad enfermado física o
psicológicamente a qué se debe este
riesgo abrumador que corren los hombres
solamente por el hecho de serlo
a la creencia de que un hombre debe
demostrar con la violencia que lo es es
decir una masculinidad a prueba a través
de la violencia
existen fuertes condicionamientos
culturales que influyen en la forma en
que vamos educando a los niños con estas
creencias con estas mentalidades desde
la pequeña infancia hasta la vida adulta
el niño debe demostrar en los juegos
peleando a ver quién es más hombre a
veces los padres le dicen no te dejes de
ese chaval o si te dejas a que te pego
yo en la casa anda golpearlo y bueno
luego los jóvenes adolescentes en las
pandillas se enfrentan todos los días en
la región centroamericana y mueren por
lo menos en el salvador en guatemala 20
jóvenes cada día y en gran medida mueren
por razones de género no se dice eso se
diabla de la pobreza se habla de
aspectos de seguridad se habla de la
criminalidad pero no se dice que me que
mueren midiendo fuerzas con otros
hombres para ver quién es más actual y
que él es más macho y eso es un factor
muy importante del que queremos hablar
esta noche
se trata de morir como hombres y cuando
ya estás muerto quién piensa que eres
más hombres
la cultura patriarcal impone al hombre
una duda sobre su identidad y le exige
como prueba de su masculinidad de
distanciarse y apartarse completamente
de las conductas consideradas femeninas
como cual es cómo expresar emociones o
sentimientos como mostrarse empáticos al
sufrimiento ajeno como optar por el
diálogo antes que por la confrontación
como renunciar a una venganza por
ejemplo y muchas otras es decir todo
aquello que es considerado un signo de
debilidad algo femenino lo peor que le
puede pasar a un hombre es que le diga
mujercita o sea que se parece a nosotras
o sea que somos lo peor
no se han dado cuenta de que este es un
insulto que también ofende no solamente
a las mujeres sino la dimensión humana
de cada hombre porque eso que se llama
femenino no es femenino es humano pero
al hombre se le priva desde la infancia
porque se le castra emocionalmente desde
la infancia y se le aparta de su
dimensión emocional cuando las emociones
son reprimidas de esta forma cuando un
hombre no puede expresarse
emocionalmente por miedo al qué dirán a
menos que esté borracho entonces si
entonces el hombre se va convirtiendo
el hombre se va convirtiendo poco a poco
en una bomba de tiempo un adolescente
por ejemplo que ha tenido que callarse y
no puede expresar su dolor por haber
sido abandonado maltratado o herido
dañado abusado esa persona en la
adolescencia en la vida adulta va a
explotar un día porque tiene demasiadas
emociones negativas reprimidas porque se
le ha prohibido expresarlas a lo largo
de toda su vida yo recuerdo un joven de
los miles de jóvenes con los que
trabajamos que me decía una vez en un
taller a mí no me ve no me pide que le
vaya a decir que me quiere que a mi mamá
que la quiero por favor me dice yo pongo
a chatear a alguien pueda saltar a
alguien pero a mí me da miedo ir a
decirle a mi mamá que la quiero
porque ese miedo a expresar sentimientos
tan grandes le sudaban las manos estaba
muy nervioso
porque desde la infancia al machismo se
le ha presentado al hombre como una
manifestación exitosa de su personalidad
todos estos comportamientos estos roles
machistas de los que muchos de nosotros
y nosotras sabemos realmente se venden
como el éxito de un hombre machista
ojalá yo quiero ser como él tiene un
montón de mujeres esto es lo otro como
lo máximo pero realmente realmente los
hombres van a ser víctimas de esa receta
de masculinidad que enferma al hombre y
que lo aleja de su dimensión humana esto
se le enseña en la familia con los
ejemplos del padre de los otros hombres
adultos hermanos mayores en la escuela
ya lo sabemos en la televisión es
abrumador la violencia masculina el
enfrentamiento yo recuerdo que de niña
sólo mirábamos a los vaqueros dispararse
en las películas ahora es terminator
masacrar uno masacrar al otro y mientras
más matamos más masculinidad más éxito
en esa masculinidad el cine los
videojuegos estamos abrumados
de violencia que se nos vende como éxito
de la masculinidad
pero además todo esto ocurre en un
momento histórico muy interesante al
hombre se le ha despojado de un rol muy
asociado a la masculinidad que es el rol
de trabajador y por proveedor cuántos
hombres en el mundo han perdido su
trabajo su empleo y con ello no
solamente han perdido un ingreso han
entrado en crisis en su propia
masculinidad es un hombre que se siente
frustrado que siente que no puede
desempeñarse en los roles masculinos que
se espera que el desempeñe al mismo
tiempo está que este desempleo ha
generado una profunda crisis por lo
tanto en esos roles masculinos una
crisis en el machismo tradicional muchos
hombres se sienten frustrados e
incómodos porque en el mismo periodo
histórico las mujeres han ganado dinero
se han abierto camino en la vida laboral
se han incorporado a la vida pública
entonces ha habido un cambio en las
relaciones de poder entre hombres y
mujeres las mujeres han obtenido
ingresos que han alterado las relaciones
de poder
la familia antes eran los hombres los
que ganaban y las mujeres mucho menos o
no trabajaban o estaban sólo en la casa
ahora en muchos hogares las mujeres son
las que obtienen más ingresos y eso ha
alterado las relaciones de poder pero no
han cambiado las mentalidades las
mujeres hemos salido a la vida pública
pero los hombres no han entrado a la
vida familiar a la vida privada las
mujeres desempeñamos roles que nunca
antes se habían desempeñado y nos
sorprende cada día ver más y más mujeres
en estos roles pero los hombres
hay realmente los hombres al entrado a
la vida familiar han entrado a la vida
doméstica no no lo han hecho los hombres
no están cerca de sus hijos abrazando
besando a sus hijos interesándose por la
educación por la crianza esto no ha
ocurrido
los roles machistas seguir estos roles
machistas realmente no es no es cierto
que conduce al éxito en la vida conduce
a la infelicidad entonces no solamente
el machismo es una receta para morir
joven sino también para la infelicidad
es la paternidad que se le prohíbe al
hombre desde que chiquito no juegas con
boyacá te vas a volver raro eso es de
mujercita y cosas peores el hombre va
desde niño siendo empujado a demostrar
con su vida que es hombre o con su juego
violento la promiscuidad sexual es otro
requisito de masculinidad que no
necesariamente es un camino hacia la
felicidad el hombre es visto como un
gesto económico un hombre sin trabajo
sin empleo no yo no quiero salir con vos
no te las reales no me interesas
entonces el hombre también es visto como
un objeto económico y las mujeres son
vistas como un objeto sexual intercambio
sexo y dinero lo otro es la dependencia
hacia la mujer muchos hombres tienen una
excesiva dependencia que la verdad es
que en el proceso de crianza las madres
hemos creado esa dependencia no hijito
no la ves no cocines tu hermanita va a
hacer todo yo lo voy a hacer todo y eso
lo va y le vais pidiendo destrezas para
la vida al hombre y la dependencia hacia
el alcohol porque mucho de las
adicciones a las drogas al alcohol tiene
que ver con esa represión emocional bajo
los efectos del alcohol un hombre puede
llorar y nadie le va a decir mujercita
le van a decir pobrecito picadito le
hacemos una sopa lo que sea
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay que tomárselo con humor pero hay
mucho dolor de por medio es urgente la
liberación masculina del machismo así
como se habló muchos años de la
liberación femenina llegó el momento de
la liberación masculina es
verdaderamente una necesidad el hombre
liberado del machismo tiene más
autoestima el hombre liberado del
machismo es más capaz de dar y recibir
amor este es un paso importantísimo
nosotros hemos visto el cambio en miles
de hombres al enfocarnos en una
masculinidad distinta en una
masculinidad libre de estos roles hemos
constatado en nuestro trabajo en el
centro de prevención de la violencia que
las tasas de delito disminuyen
rápidamente por ejemplo hicimos una
investigación en un barrio en ese barrio
durante seis meses intervenimos con la
con este modelo con toda esta
metodología y la tasa de delitos
disminuyó en 53 por ciento en el barrio
de control aumentó en el mismo período
de seis meses en 16% todos los delitos
eso significa que esto puede funcionar y
por eso nosotros creemos que debe ser
considerada esta visión este enfoque en
la prevención de la violencia por ello
mismo hemos capacitado en guatemala el
salvador honduras nicaragua chile
argentina uruguay méxico colombia en
varios países hemos capacitado a mucha
gente pero en centroamérica tenemos 12
mil multiplicadores de esta metodología
qué pasaría y esto quisiera
preguntárselo yo a ustedes ahorita qué
pasaría soñemos por un segundo
imaginemos que en nicaragua nos
despertamos mañana y en el 80% de los
hogares hay un padre presente pero no
solo presente físicamente afectuoso
cercano en los procesos de crianza a sus
hijos capaz de comunicarse con el
corazón con sus hijos interesados en lo
que pasa en la vida en sus hijos tan
cercanos a los hijos como la madre qué
ocurriría en la familia qué ocurriría en
el país cuando yo hago esta pregunta
en muchos auditorios donde él ha hecho
hay una consenso abrumador abrió una
profunda y decisiva transformación
social
menos violencia en la familia menos
violencia en las calles menos delitos en
general menos presos en las cárceles
menos adicciones a distinto a la droga
al alcohol al tabaco a todo lo que nos
está destruyendo pero sobre todo habrían
cambios incluso aún más trascendentales
seríamos mucho más felices como sociedad
habría menos deserción escolar mejoría
mejoraría la salud pública incluso me
habría un enfrentamiento mucho más
efectivo en la pobreza porque la pobreza
tiene que ver con esto con estas
creencias y con estas mentalidades que
impiden el desarrollo humano porque
realmente afectan las relaciones
familiares cómo podemos lograr esto
tenemos que empezar ya desde nuestros
hogares con nuestros hijos con los niños
más próximos a nosotros en nuestras
escuelas en los entornos más inmediatos
educamos a los niños para expresar
libremente sus emociones
enseñémosles hacerlo no tengamos miedo
de esto no tengamos perdamos
ahora el qué dirán ay qué van a decir si
mi muchachito juega con muñecas no le
vamos a decir
amorcito estás aprendiendo a ser papá
estás aprendiendo como tu hermanita que
está aprendiendo a ser mamá estás
aprendiendo a ser papá
pero perdamos el temor porque hay mucho
miedo al qué dirán vamos no va a ser
fácil probablemente pero vale la pena
intentarlo cuando lo hacemos y vemos
cómo me acuerdo una amiga que me decía
yo nunca le regalaba muñecos y que hacía
mi hijito agarraba el camioncito que yo
le regalaba y chin ya va el camión
entonces los hombres si tienen ese
sentimiento de amor pero lo vamos les
vamos impidiendo prohibiendo
desarrollarlo
los gobiernos y la sociedad en general
tienen los medios de comunicación una
inmensa responsabilidad no basta con que
cada persona nos comprometamos las
instituciones deben empujar esto sobre
todo en las políticas educativas en los
medios de comunicación en las políticas
culturales debemos empezar a cambiar
estos roles de género que tanto daño nos
hacen a hombres ya mujeres
yo quisiera decirles ahora algo más
personal cuando yo tenía 7 años murió mi
padre era un inmigrante que dejó su país
ya su madre y nunca volvió a su país que
nunca volvió a ver a su madre que sufría
calladamente y yo lo veía distante
alejado era un hombre bueno pero muy
distante y la verdad hubiese querido yo
saber que había en su corazón que tanto
le costaba expresar por eso dedico esta
presentación a mi padre y a los hombres
que como él sufren calladamente el
machismo el que sufren calladamente ese
mandato cultural del machismo y que como
él mueren tempranamente en gran medida a
causa de ello muchas gracias
[Aplausos]